welcome to da 300
awesome new features to help you manage
bigquery
my name is tino teresco and i'm a
product manager on google bigquery
so bigquery historically has been a
serverless data warehouse
which kind of means a lot of things to a
lot of folks but in practicality what it
means to you is that you get a limited
scale
the core is very easy to use it
automatically self-optimizing
um there's no virtual machine related
performance clips of kind of unexpected
behaviors
it's got a high level of reliability and
a lot of other features
and of course we recently announced that
we now have an industry best four
nines of availability in rsla so all of
these are benefits of serverless that
you
get as a bigquery customer now
um folks who are on the far
end of the maturity spectrum right at
large enterprises multinational
organizations
they actually do want more control more
predictability so over the years we
built out a number of
features and functionalities that enable
those organizations take the
control of bigquery while kind of
getting the best of bigquery being
serverless
in fact we kind of built bigquery to be
for everyone right whether you're a
startup whether you're a student you're
just kind of experimenting in your
garage
we have functionality for that right
where you care about simplicity ease of
use
you want to experiment quickly and then
as you're growing and you have larger
scales
you want more flexibility you want more
efficiency you want more predictability
we give you that functionality and again
all the way out to the largest
enterprises
where you have potentially exabyte-scale
use cases
you want control you want predictability
you won't monitor and you want
administration
so we are there to provide you
functionality
wherever you are on this gradient and
actually if you move
from the startup to growth to large
enterprises you can take advantage of
the various functionalities that we have
here
brilliant so let me illustrate um this
whole concept uh through a fictional
company um
and so why not spruce up the
administration topic with a little bit
of cats
um so this is actually my cat rascal um
he's just
like any other cat he's got a lot of
personality and his interests really
include maps he really likes being pet
um he stalks the neighborhood quite a
bit right so that's his primary things
in life that he cares about
so what if we used carriage technology
to really figure out what rascal does
all day
and what he thinks and what drives him
to really provide a better user
experience for rasco
so with that in mind we thought about
critical feline requirements so short
for cfrs really
and so the first topic of course is naps
so what do we need to know about
rascal's naps well we need to know how
often he naps
where he maps locations and actually
total nap time right
which tends to be about 20 hours a week
uh 20 hours a day
the second one is rascal loves being pet
but he does you know there's a certain
threshold to petting so we need to know
what is this optimal number of paddings
that he can sustain
um does he like to be pat on the belly
does it like to be better on the head
that's very critical to understand
and finally for our sakes we need to
know
um how likely is rascal to be upset if
we give him just one more pet that's
really important to know and finally the
third interest of rascal is he's talking
the neighborhood
so we need to know the perimeter that
he's patrolling what is his territory
and you know a different cataract down
the street has a
different territory we need to know how
often he patrols it
and maybe we can even matt uh map the
social network of rascal and how he
interacts with all the other cats these
are all really really critical things to
know about felines
so with that extent we're introducing 23
and meow
this is a brand new innovative startup
it's internet of cats
uh what 23 and meow does is it provides
smart connected collars for cats
let me explain so you put this collar on
your cat
and the smart collar has lots of
different centers
sensors that collect telemetry data in
real time
so there is a geospatial capability so
it gets locational rascal
there's a temperature sensor there's an
accelerator meters that will tell you
what the velocity of your cat traveling
and the acceleration um there's also a
microphone
and a camera so you can identify sounds
and even take video and pictures
so all of that data gets captured and
collected in real time
and then we perform predictive real-time
analytics on that information
and so in a sense we give you a better
picture of what your cat does all day
and what are your cats preferences it's
beautiful
so let's take a look at the tech stack
all right so
23 may and meow heavily relies on big
quarry in fact it's essentially the only
thing that 23andme i was doing
they picked bigquery because um it's
very easy to get started
it's time to mark it as critical because
there are other similar startups that
are trying to do the same thing
so 23 and meow wanted to pick technology
that's serverless
that's easy to get going with and also
easy to grow with
so let's walk through this technology
stack so first of all
we already talked about how a number of
center sensors are sending data
into bigquery in real time that includes
geospatial sensors right so geospatial
data comes into bigquery
point number two this data is ingested
in real time using bigquery's unique
real-time apis
to get that data into bigquery for
immediate access
number three bigquery's new integration
with auto ml and the cloud ai stack
enables us to perform machine learning
right inside of the data warehouse right
inside of the query
on this real-time data so we've
developed cad behavior models like
danger of incremental paddings how about
the favorite body part to be pet on
and actually favorite naptime locations
these are all really advanced machine
learning technologies that we've
implemented here
to develop this functionality and number
four we have a number of public data
sets that we include
that we enrich our data with so for
example weather
right that depends what your cad does
depending what the weather outside is
and then we're using materialized views
and removing the data into bi
engine and that's number five and of
course a new upcoming api engine
enhancements
allow you to run bigquery sql on top of
bi engine
and number six looker that recently
joined our family
is used for dashboarding of this data so
this is an entire stack that essentially
lives
on top of bigquery now if you take a
look at those things one through six
all those things are essentially unique
to bigquery or almost unique
uh which means that you don't need to
build out a number of different
technologies together take advantage of
all these things
this is all integrated right into
bigquery for you
it's beautiful so we started out small
right we rolled out our startup we have
a few
trusted caps that we're using and so
we're just using bigquery's perpetual
free tier
if you're not familiar you get 10
gigabytes of storage for free
every single month and you get a
terabyte of data processed every single
month
and we do this in perpetuity no strings
attached you can keep using that free
tier
for as long as you want but now that
we've kind of expanded our offer and be
beyond the trusted cats um and now we
have a
thousand cats that were that are using
our caller
so we're growing with bigquery right
we're on that gradient
and so we're using the bigquery's
on-demand bytes processed model
right this is a billing model that is
purely consumption
you're only paying for what you consume
you pay per query
right so there's no wastage it's super
efficient and there's zero administrator
overhead you don't have to think about
anything there's nothing to set up but
if you want to kind of manage your cost
and make sure there's no
you know runaway bills or anything like
that we're leveraging cost controls
beautiful so now we've thought about how
do we expand our offering to make things
more interesting so we introduced
an additional sensor to our cat collars
that actually measures cat pheromones
it kind of actually smells what the cat
smells like and it tracks the cat
pheromone
excretions and then runs machine
learning models to understand what your
cat is feeling
at that particular moment so this is
called the emotions api
and it's available to all of our 23andme
customers today
so on the back of the emotions api
23andmeal has become
really successful we now have a whole 1
million daily active cats
phenomenal success but now actually our
infrastructure cost
is starting to grow as well right we're
we're running more analytics we're using
more cpu and ram
we have more dashboards so our leverage
of bigquery is growing and so we need to
start kind of worrying about
maybe monitoring it maybe administering
it a little bit more
and so the question pops up very
typically with bigquery customers
is are slots right for me right for the
uninitiated
there's two billing models on phobicore
there's the buyer's process model the
most customers start out with
and then there's the slots model and the
slots model is optional
it tends to be for the larger customers
and it has some really nice benefits
so the question is are the bigquery
slots the right for me
well in order to help our customers
figuring out if that is the right option
we're launching something called
bigquery slot recommendations it's
currently in
alpha so this is advanced machine
learning logic
that we will run on your usage data
and of course using you know all the
right privacy controls and we will tell
you proactively whether the slots model
is the right model for you
without sacrificing performance so you
could potentially save money
without sacrificing performance which is
fantastic
and of course the other pricing
recommendation that we launched
kind of helps you figure out whether you
need to use monthly slots
or annual slots go use that today
and there's a related session called
cnp100 that talks about that
in a little bit of a greater depth
so what are bigquery slots it's a very
frequent question that i hear
well it's simply a slot is a cpu
right that's you can think about it like
that um and a cpu
processes your queries runs analytics so
whenever you purchase a slot or a number
of slots
you purchase analytic processing
capability your purse is purchased
throughput
which means that a number of slots that
you have will either
give you faster queries or will give you
more queries to run at the same time or
both
right you're kind of buying a cluster of
bigquery with bigquery slots
and you can buy slots today in um
with us per second commitment per month
or per year
um the per second commitment is called
flex slots and there's no difference
between those slots
except for flex slots you can cancel
just after 60 seconds
so you can use them whenever and cancel
them whenever
but they're a little bit more expensive
monthly slots you commit to an entire
month
so you can't change um you you you can't
cancel them
or downsize them uh for the duration of
a month but you get a little bit of a
discount on that
and then annual is of course the most um
the cheapest option but the least
flexible right you commit to a full year
for that capacity
but you get a discount so how
are queries using slots let's talk about
that
so a query really inside of bigquery is
the dynamic
dag directed acrylic graph what that
means is
it's uh what does dynamic mean dynamic
means
that as the query progresses um our
query execution plan
changes right we learn more about what
you're trying to do
or learn more about the data patterns
and we decide
on the fly the best path of execution
this is really really powerful it really
accelerates queries for you
um but what does the dag part be the dag
part means that
a bigquery query is a series of stages
now they can run in parallel they can
run serially there's all kinds of
patterns that we can
um that are leveraged there and the each
stage is essentially a tiny mini query
in its own
right um each stage has a
parallelization factor
anywhere from one to i've seen billions
which basically bigquery says
i can parallelize this particular stage
of the query by
so and sole amount and it's very typical
to to have this sterilization factor in
thousands
um and a slot is essentially
that cpu that executes a single
parallelization
unit of a single stage so in this
particular picture
you see the first stage has 10 000
uh a fertilization factor of 10 000.
that means that bigquery could use
up to 10 000 slots at any point in time
to uh to execute this particular stage
of the query but now
if ten thousand slots is a lot of slots
if you have a little bit fewer than ten
thousand slots
we will simply burn through that those
um
the slots that are not available uh with
time right so let's say if you have 500
slots
500 slots will execute that stage and
then 9 500 slots will essentially queue
up
and then as the first 500 slots free up
um they will burn through that pen top
demand with time
and so think of a query as a series of
stages
and each stage consumes any number from
one to
billions of slots potentially and each
stage doesn't have to get all its slots
it will kind of wait for the slots to
come in hopefully i explained that well
for you
now when you have multiple queries
running concurrently what happens in
bigquery
we use this concept called fair
scheduling what that means is
each query gets equal right to the
available provision slots
now if a small query comes in it doesn't
have to use its equal right it
potentially could use only a single slot
if it's a small chord
or on the opposite on the spectrum a
query could request millions of slots
but they get equal right to the capacity
that's available
now i've mentioned this before already
if a query doesn't get a hundred percent
of its requested slots
um those slots just kind of queue up
right so it will burn through that uh
pen top capacity
um as slots become available
and the final thing i want to mention is
bigquery continuously does this
recalculation
um this happens in real time so whenever
new queries come in
we will redistribute slots in line now
the effect here
is quarries speed up or slow down in
real time
rather than kind of uh cancel or
anything like that
so let me give an example so here on the
right side you'll see that the
environment has
2 000 slots in total and there's four
quarters running in there and they're
fairly large quarries
so each one is asking for 500 slots
so um for the maximum amount of slots
so our fair scheduler will actually give
each quarry 500
slots and let's say a fifth query comes
in that's a large query and it needs a
lot of slots as well
what we're going to do automatically in
real time is we're going to take a
hundred slots away from each of the four
queries we'll just pause that work we're
not going to waste it
and we will give it to the fifth chord
so now we have five quarries
running with 400 slots each what that
did to the
original four quarters it just made them
a little bit slower than before
so the system works really really well
it actually biases against
large runaway quarries right and it
biases four smaller quarries that are
higher
that have lower latency requirements so
it's a very very useful uh pattern
so the query slots pricing let's talk
about the benefits here
the first one of course is it's
predictable
right you control how much you spend
right you explicitly tell us
i want to purchase x amount of slots and
it's gonna cost me a certain amount of
money
now i mentioned before we have three
types of commitments we have monthly
annual and flex slots monthly and annual
um require you to commit to 30 days or a
full year
and flex slots essentially have no
commitment period so you can purchase
them and cancel them whenever you want
the other thing is we don't rely on
t-shirt sizes you can
buy slots in a number of granularities
and that's really really powerful
the second part i should say is a lot of
features come
with slots we don't have a special type
of slots that you have to purchase
in order to get materialized views we
don't have a special type of slot you
need to purchase in order to buy
advanced security features
like customer master encryption keys
like time travel like ddos protection
that we provide
um all of that is included in slots we
also do
things like batch ingest we actually
doesn't consume your slot capacity
it doesn't contend with your uh queries
and it comes from
comes from somewhere else so you really
don't pay for batch ingest at all
and we also do a lot of background
processes
like automatic reclustering that we
don't charge for at all
right so it's something that we provide
to you as a service to make sure that
your queries are running exceptionally
well and we don't charge you for it
now and and of course the industry best
four nines of sla
just comes with any slot right you don't
have to pay extra for it
i should also mention that all of these
properties um you get with buys process
model as well
and finally because we are serverless
because we're not
bound to virtual machines we get to
provide some really interesting benefits
to you
right our architecture is very unique in
that sense so the first one is
we can provision capacity almost
instantly right we don't have virtual
machines to spin up or provision for you
we don't need to move data into your
virtual machine to get performance
right it's just serverless it just lives
there so for now
scaling is just a number change the
other thing is
of course the virtual machine doesn't
have to be pre-warmed data doesn't need
to be moved into the virtual machine
so you get optimal performance
immediately and the final bit that's a
little bit hard to capture but it's
really really important for real life
use cases
whenever you increase capacity it
impacts
your quarries in flight immediately so
if you have a quarry that's running
inside of your environment
and you need to accelerate that core
adding more capacity will do that
immediately
you don't have to undo the query cancel
the quarry and start our new one right
quarters in flight benefit from capacity
changes
fantastic one last comment on the
different
commitment types i want to make it
really really clear so we have three
commitment types flex slots monthly and
annual
and so think about what is the proper
use case for how to combine these
you don't have to use only one of those
types it's just slots again
and the difference is the length of the
commitment and price
so you can think about a workload by
workload you can have a steady state
monthly or annual commitments there um
that
are used 24 7 right and you get a lower
price for them
and then you can use flex slots to have
kind of like dispersed addition capacity
um to the steady state that is used for
seconds minutes
hours or potentially days right so you
can combine these two and that becomes
really really powerful
i'm really delighted to announce that
today we're offering a hundred slot
pricing
so before today you have to commit to
500 slots uh which admittedly
is a little bit on you know quite of a
lot for
a number of our customers right so with
a monthly contract
500 slots was ten thousand dollars a
month so a lot of our customers really
wanted to start using slots pricing but
they wanted a lower price point
so we're introducing a hundred slots
what that means is on a monthly contract
it's two thousand dollars per month on
an annual contract to seventeen hundred
dollars per month
and on a flex contract it's just four
dollars per hour
right so you can purchase a hundred
slots cancel them after one hour
and you only pay four dollars so it's
really expensive
and i'm hoping that a lot of our
customers embrace this model
we'll continue to expand our
administration functionality in many
different ways
so admin panel ui is one of those
investments that we're making
it's on the roadmap we're hoping to make
it available in the next few months
essentially what the administration
panel ui does it's it's a bigquery
native uh monitoring and administration
platform
it allows you to chart how you're using
bigquery in real time
so it's going to allow you to monitor
slots resources queries
jobs users and so on so forth
you're also be able to do this in real
time and historically going back
30 days or more which means that you can
zoom in and zoom out depending on the
use case
for the real time use case you can
identify
um whether somebody in your organization
is using too much um
and perform root cause analysis in that
way whereas if you zoom out historically
you'll be able to decide whether you
need more capacity or less capacity
based on your their various usage
patterns
the next set of features that we've
recently launched is information scheme
of use
um now a number of these views are
available some of them are general
availability
and what these views allow you to do is
in real time and historically again
you can see everything that's going on
inside of the court
so today we have available jobs and
reservations views
we're going to be soon launching uh
streaming views so if you're streaming
that into bigquery you can see what's
happening there error rates bytes
bytes ingested things like that we're
also going to provide storage views
so you can see how much data is stored
in each of your column each of your
partition each of your table and how
it's being used
and eventually we're going to actually
get into permissions as well so some of
the benefits of information schema that
we provide
well for one it's just automatically
managed by us it's
the data that we provide for you um and
we don't we don't charge you for the
storage
so that's really nice it's just there
and you can start using it
um it's live right so this is consistent
sub
uh sub second latency of information
that provides that's provided to you
it's also historical so we get up to six
months of historical information
in these tables automatically free of
charge
the other benefit is for larger
organizations that have lots and lots of
projects
we provide you an organization-wide view
so you don't have to
kind of query every single project to
figure out what's going on
you can query information schema tables
for your entire organization
um so there's lots of really interesting
use cases on top of um that you can
leverage these
tables with
past forward a few months and 23ml has
been really really successful but
we've decided to launch some new
features because we
have been capturing sound for a long
time using our
uh our microphone on these colors we
started developing machine learning
models
to help us understand what the cat is
actually saying
and then we've developed a two-way
language api
that allows us to understand cats but
also to communicate
back so it will actually translate human
english
language only english is supported for
now
into cat meows and purse so allows us to
communicate directly with the cat
this is a fantastic feature um and it
immediately propelled us
uh to become a global phenomenon right
we have today a
billion daily active cats um and we're a
multinational organization we operate in
145 countries it's
just an amazing success that we've
experienced so far
but we've grown so fast and so
you know we we are a large organization
now but we're still using bigquery as
the same core of our technology
so how do we obtain more control what
kinds of problems are we facing as a
billion daily active cat organization
so for one is we really care about price
we're about to go ipo
um and so we need to kind of get our
finances in order
so we need to control the cost we need
to control the cost of the organization
as a whole
and we need to control the
programization all the way down to
individual users
we also have some really critical slas
we actually
run our machine learning models often
right in the court
so those are very important workloads
that we have and we need to make sure
that those get the right resources
and they finish in the right amounts of
time so that's critical for us to have
vocal management capability
and the third one is cost attribution
again we should be able to trace
every single action that's happening in
our environment and uh
down to the user that has caused that
action so that we can attribute costs
so these are all very much enterprise
grade billion daily active cap problems
that we're facing
so to support these use cases we
launched bigquery reservations this is a
general availability platform
for workload management and cost
management inside of the court
corey reservations today enables you to
purchase slot commitments in seconds
again monthly annual no flex types
then you can take that capacity and you
can
uh you can departmentalize you can
isolate and partition it into individual
departments or teams
or sets of users right so if you have x
amount of capacity
you want to give the individual use
cases their isolated pools
so we allow you to do that and finally
it allows you to share
any unused capacity across your
organization so in the periods when
there's not a lot going on
that capacity is not wasted it's
available for the rest of your
organization to be used seamlessly
and automatically so let's think of a
typical use case of how reservations are
used in practice
so let's say we figured out that a
thousand slots is what we need in terms
of capacity
and we said the 500 of those slots are
going to be our steady state slots
and we can lock them in on a very
inexpensive annual contract
and then 500 slots are going to be flex
slots simply because maybe we want to
have more or less we're not entirely
sure
so we do want that flexibility but in
total we have a thousand slots that's
our capacity for data processing right a
slot is a slot
step number two we're gonna take those a
thousand slots and we have three
different business units
we have the team that manages pheromones
api
we have a team that manages the
languages api and we have a team
that manages bi all the dashboards
that's three separate teams within our
organizations
and the pheromones is of course where we
make all of our money
so we're going to give them 500 slots
the languages team is really important
but it's a newer feature so we're going
to give them 300 slots
and then bi is going to get 200 slots so
we've partitioned these workloads into
these departments
and finally the third step is we
assigned all the relevant projects
to these reservations and off we go
that's all we have to do set and forget
here's a new feature that's going to
help even further with this type of use
case
bigquery slots auto scaling is coming
soon
with bigquery slots auto scaling does is
it automatically provisions
and deeper business capacity for you
based on how are you using our platform
right so it's really really advanced
functionality so again because we're not
running on virtual machines because we
are serverless we're
able to do to give you a lot of benefits
the traditional virtual machine based
data warehouse cannot
uh for one is we have zero second
warm-up
the moment you get your capacity
provisioned your capacities are 100
performance there's no such thing as
hydrating your local disk to make sure
the performance is optimal
the second as i already mentioned
whenever you increase capacity your
queries in flight take advantage of that
immediately
the third is again because we're not
running on local disk
because we're not relying on local
storage there are no unexpected
behaviors like performance clips when
the local storage goes away or gets
saturated
right we don't rely on local storage we
have true separation of storage and
compute
and finally we expressed this in our sla
is we're immune to downtime for
individual nodes
all the way to a large portion of a data
center and that's why we're able to
provide four nines of the sla
so let's talk about slots r scanning a
little bit more
so all we're doing here is we're adding
one additional variable to the
reservations configuration
it's called max auto scaling limit
um and so let's walk through this
example right so what we did is for the
fair amounts reservation
we set the auto scalar limit to be 300
and for the bi reservation we set the
auto scaling limit to be a thousand
right and so we did this per reservation
that's where this configuration lives
but we didn't enable this on the
language reservation
and so what happens is whenever the fair
amounts reservation needs more than 500
slots
it will try to get that 500 slots from
across the rest of the organization
we'll try to see if the language's
reservation has auto capacity
or if the bi reservation has auto
capacity
and then it's going to say well i still
need more capacity than that because i
have a lot of
a lot of data processing to do and only
then
will reservations auto scale and kick in
only then we will
increase your capacity by 300 slots
which is fantastic right so
the only way auto scaling kicks in is if
the entire organization is saturated and
there is no idle slots to be had
and then if the capacity is no longer
necessary
will automatically down scale your
reservation so pheromones will go from
500 slots to 800 slots and down
whereas bi will go from 200 to 1200
slots
and down now something i should mention
is that the
current um version of auto scaling that
we're working on
is binary which means that we will only
increase to the maximum amount
or back to the minimum amount right so
in this example the pheromones
reservation will only be a size 500
or size 800. there's no intermediate
state
and of course eventually we will have
all these advanced autoscaling
modes as well so how does
auto scaling work with steady state
capacity
well really you think about it you can
purchase monthly annual flex commitments
and keep them
as steady state capacity that is always
there that's guaranteed for you
and then you can turn on our scaling on
top of it to provide burst
and it's managed for you right auto
scaling only kicks in
when necessary how do you pay for it
well what we do is we purchase flex
slots for you
so auto scaling underneath the hood uses
flex
slots and so you play pay the flex slots
rates
now here's a really really advanced
capability that auto scaling provides
for you
starting from zero this is kind of
called the auto pause or auto start
use case so in this example we actually
have zero commitments we've purchased
zero slots and all of our reservations
are sized to be zero
which means that there's not a single
slot purchase to provisioned
um and you pay us nothing in terms of
analytic capability
but we set auto scaling for each
reservation right so pheromones language
bi they all have auto scaling
limits set in this mode whenever a query
comes into the environment we will
immediately scale the reservation to its
maximum limit
and the query will execute immediately
and now up on the opposite side whenever
your
reservation is idle we will diminish it
back to zero
right so this is essentially auto pause
auto start
your bigquery environment will only
operate when you run in queries
and it will shut down when your queries
are not running which will enable you to
save a good amount of money
so i've talked about a number of
features that enable you to kind of
traverse the gradient of growth right
from a tiny little startup or just
trying to go to market quickly
to a mid-size organization all the way
to a multinational organization with
complex requirements
and complex needs and reporting and so
on and so forth
so let's kind of summarize everything
that we've talked about so on the
pricing front
we have flex slots that went ga at the
end of june
we recently launched 100 slots so now
you can purchase capacity
for as little as two thousand uh two
thousand dollars a month
uh with a monthly contract or four
dollars per hour
with the flex contract and the other
thing we talked about quite a bit
is the fact that we share auto capacity
across your environment it doesn't go to
waste
the second point is workload management
capability right so once you have this
capacity
how do you actually break it up into
your departments and workloads
well reservations is the powerful
platform that enables that and it's ga
but we recently announced slots auto
scaling with that additional level of
automation
that enables you to scale up and down
and only pay for what you consume
and finally we talked about ammon panel
which is the visual ui
that will provide to help you monitor
and perform root cause analysis on your
environment
and finally intelligence higher level
data
and logic that will provide to you um
that will help you drive your decision
making so of course information schema
is a project that will have a series of
views that will enable you to get data
and slot recommendations just our first
step in this advanced intelligence
that will tell you exactly what's going
on environment and will recommend to you
further action
now actual administration knobs and
performance is just
one part of the story of course as an
administrator
oftentimes you care about performance
we'll continue to invest in this area
throughout the years we've always made
decorating faster and faster and faster
and
faster so just from this beginning of
this year alone from january 1st
we look at the industry standard tpc ds
benchmarks
and we measure our performance
performance to be anywhere from 20
to 30 and the way you get this benefit
is just the next time you run a query
you will just get a better performance
um we perform these optimizations for
you on the
um on the background we roll our code
without disturbing your environment
you just get these benefits and you get
these benefits without any additional
cost
so this is a trend that we have right
every few months we
add some better some better performance
optimizations your quarters just become
faster and faster and faster and faster
and this trend will continue in the
future
so we talked about this quite a bit
right when you're starting out
you really want the easiest path to go
to market you don't want to worry about
things
and so our serverless capability enables
you to do that there's nothing to set up
you only pay for what you consume and
off you go but
as you grow you care more about
different things you care more about
control and predictability
and so we built out a series of
capabilities that enable you to take
advantage of that
but the key is that you all of these
things are optional right
you only need to use admin panel if you
care about predictability and control
um and you're a certain size so please
be mindful of that
because we have a lot a lot of customers
that are on the larger side
but we have lots and lots of customers
that are on the free tier or have very
very little
um data inside of bigquery and that's
perfectly okay right bigquery is built
for everyone
we recently talked about trial slot so
this is a promotion for new bigquery
customers
that enables you to get 95 off of slots
so essentially you can buy 500 slots
for a duration of 6 months for 500 per
month
this is a 20th of the cost of a monthly
contract
right so just one dollar per slot per
month
of course it's just slots so you can
combine them with other types of slots
um you can you know you can combine them
with other flex slots monthly and annual
and so forth
and of course it covers all of your sql
queries that you run
right so it's in a good amount of
capacity now i should be mindful
to tell you that this is a promotion so
certain qualifications and restrictions
do apply
so finally i want to open the floor to
everyone to think about the next
10x use case for our tiny little startup
23 and meow
there's lots of things that cats can do
and we're open to collaboration we're
open to more ideas
so send me some of your ideas on twitter
to the
tino t and i really appreciate all the
time that you spent listening to me
thank you so much